Speaker 1: Welcome, everybody. Today, we're going
to be sort of resetting, taking an overview of
the political climate in the United States as
we're now. Just what is it? It's about eight,
eight, nine weeks from the 2022 midterm
elections. And one of the big stories,
one of the big contexts in which we now have to
think about these midterms and what are the next
two years of American politics sort of going to
be like is the now extraordinarily notable spike
in President Joe Biden's approval rating. Now, we
have to also understand context. And the context
is this extremely partizan status quo of the
United States, where your range of approval
probably is only between, you know, 35 and
65 or something like that. And what I mean
by that is when you divide up the electorate
into people who just don't pay attention,
and then those who will always approve of
a Democratic president and disapprove of
a Republican one, and then those who will always
disapprove of a Democratic president and approve
of a Republican one. And then you say, okay, who's
actually willing to be swayed and to sometimes
say they approve and sometimes say they don't?
Not based simply on the party of the president.
You probably only have a functional approval
range of somewhere between 35 and 65, and maybe
it's a little wider than that. We used to say
it's between 20 and 80. I don't know what it
is right now. We are continuing to see Joe Biden's
approval climb and climb and climb now up to 42.4%
in an average of approval polls. Now, this
bottomed out in mid-May. I'm sorry, in no,
not in mid-May, in the middle of July at 37.5. So
very roughly speaking, to go from 37 5 to 42 four.
You're talking about a 12 or 13 ish percent
increase, not percentage points. Everybody relax
percent, 12 to 13% increase roughly.
You can check my math on that.
Remember the storyline that at this point we used
to say at this point in Joe Biden's presidency,
he is less popular than every president dating
all the way back to Truman in I believe it was 46.
We used to say that we have a very different
situation now. Not only has Joe Biden's approval
rating gone up at a dramatic rate, but Joe Biden
now in. I'll pull these numbers up for you.
Joe Biden now has pulled even with Donald
Trump in terms of approval at this point in
their respective presidencies. Joe Biden has
pulled roughly even with Bill Clinton at this
point in their respective presidencies. Even if
you look at Reagan, Biden is now basically where
Reagan was at this point in his presidency. And
same thing if you look at Jimmy Carter as well,
and only a couple of points, interestingly enough,
only a couple of points below Barack Obama at this
point in time. So what is the meaning of all of
this? What is the importance of all this? Well,
if people don't show up to vote in the midterms,
the importance is essentially nothing. The whole
context here is historically when a president
takes the White House, when, for example,
a Democrat takes the White House from a Republican
in the first midterm election, which comes two
years later, Democrats usually don't do well.
This might mean if they have the House and Senate,
they lose both. Or it might mean if they if
they don't have them, they fall behind by an
even greater margin. We saw this in 1994 with Bill
Clinton as an example. It almost always happens,
however, and we'll look at where the numbers
are, maybe Wednesday, Thursday, as of right now,
Democrats are favored to maintain control
of the Senate, potentially even expanding
it beyond the 5050 majority they have now
with Kamala Harris is tie breaking vote.
And although the House is still statistically
very likely, it's almost 4 to 1 likely to go
to Republicans. There are now paths to Democrats
keeping control of the House. Now, I'm not
first of all, I'm not making any predictions,
but I'm not I'm not predicting that Democrats are
going to keep the House. But there is now a story
to be told. There is now a path in which you could
make that case. But it all depends on turnout.
The 2018 midterm turnout was 53%, and that was the
highest midterm turnout in four decades. What I
mean by that is midterm turnout is normally very,
very low. You don't normally get even 53% turnout.
I think the last presidential we had roughly 60%
turnout. So it is I know it's cliche at this point
to say it, but it will come down to who actually
gets voters out. And it is an opportunity with
Joe Biden's spiking approval. The humiliation that
is taking place for Trump and the MAGA movement.
It's an opportunity for Democrats to do something
that would not be historically indicated based
on what we have seen in midterms in the past.
We'll update the numbers on House and Senate
Wednesday, Thursday, by the end of the week.